there are winners and there are losers
and there are people who have not
discovered how to win there's no secret
to success there's a system to success
life is a fight for territory and once
you stop fighting for what you want
but you don't want will automatically
take over what a sore get a mentor
[Music]
so today that's learned from one of the
best Les Brown and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me les okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
believe it's possible I want you to look
at something right now thank you some
major go you want or maybe it's one you
already working on and you have
experienced a lot of setbacks a lot of
defeats you've experienced a lot of
disappointment maybe you've already
given up and maybe you just need a
little fire a little encouragement to
get back in the game again here's what I
want you to look at there are winners
and there are losers and there are
people who have not discovered how to
win and all they need is some coaching
all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support all
they need is some insight or different
strategy a plan of action to make some
adjustments that will open up the key to
a whole new future for them that will
give them access to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves that's
all that they need so what I want you to
do is think about something you want for
you that's real for you that's important
for you that will give your life some
special meaning and power and I don't
even want you to say I can do that I
don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when I started out in this
area I would not have been able to make
the mental leap that I would be up to
where I am right now I don't want you to
begin to just psych yourself out no no I
want you to be able to say something to
yourself that will enable you to
maintain a level of integrity with
yourself that when you say this even
when you face tremendous setbacks it it
will be a benchmark to keep you in the
game to keep you moving forward in
experimenting and readjusting your
strategy and your plan of action
continuously look
four ways to win so what is that
something when you got an idea you want
to move on you might not have the money
you might not have the education you
might not have the support or the
resources you need what is that
something that can keep us going that
will enable us to act on our dream
what's one of those keys that will begin
to help us to discover the secrets to
our dream here's what I want you to
repeat after me please with power and
conviction say it's possible that's all
I want you to do when you look at your
dream you say to yourself every day it's
possible just say that everyday to them
it's possible because what does that do
see it begins to change your belief
system so the way in which we operate
ladies and gentlemen it's a
manifestation of what we believe what's
possible for us whatever you've done up
to this point all that it really is is a
duplication it's a reproduction of what
you believe subconsciously that you
deserve and what's possible for your
life before in April 1954 the common
belief the universe will believe because
it had been tried again and again and
again and people that fail the belief
was that man was not physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier that
he could not wanna mile in less than
four minutes that was to believe on the
planet it had never been done but here's
what happened ladies and gentlemen Roger
Bannister came along and he broke the
four-minute barrier now here's what's
significant about that since that time
up to this day over 20,000 people have
done it including high school kids what
changed
20,000 people what change here's what
happened when they got on the track they
knew it had been done and because they
knew it had been done there was a new
belief about this barrier about this
goal that was unreachable and those
20,000 people got into raised believing
knowing in the heart that someone had
done it that it's possible that they
could do it and I'm saying that if you
know anybody that had some goals some
dreams something they wanted to do and
they did it denies saying that you know
in your heart that if someone has done
it then you can do it it's possible and
that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's it's possible
that you can make your dream become
reality rule number two be willing to
work there's no secret to success
there's a system to success and no
matter what organization you become a
part of the system works if you work it
if you don't work it it won't work but
it works if you work it and that's one
four-letter word that most people don't
like they're not willing to work I have
a friend who had invited me to her
brother's house to help him to get off
drugs to introduce him to a drug program
that can help him and and I said these
people can help you but you've got to be
willing to do the work and after we
finish he asked us to leave and I'll
never forget what she said as we were
going down the steps
she said les I do apologize for wasting
your time but I realize when my brother
knew that it would require work for him
and get off drugs that most people won't
participate in their own rescue and
there are people who will be presented
with an opportunity who know that they
could be laid off at any moment who know
that there's no such thing as job
security who know that they're keeping
their job has nothing to do with how
good
and yet and still they'll go to work and
have-nots in their stomachs hoping when
they open up an email that they have not
been told this is your last day they'll
go to work hoping there's not a security
guard standing by their desk with a box
and say empty your things in here and
take them to the front door and escort
them to the parking lot they go in there
hoping it doesn't happen why because
they don't want to do
it's an aversion to most people's spirit
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 2:54 confident series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below we have so much energy
that can take us so far it's necessary
that you hook up with some other energy
that can take you to the next level I
hooked up with him less and less let's
go us and away we go
it's necessary if you're going to
compete today that you look for ways to
amaze your customers rule number three
fail your way to success if you
constantly remind yourself after every
defeat after every setback every time
you get knocked down I've got a saying
if life knocks you down try and land on
your back because if you can look up you
can get up see a lot of people because
of failure they stop they stop believing
let me share something with you you will
fail your way to success yes eight out
of ten millionaires have been
financially bankrupt you will fail your
way to success it doesn't matter how
many times you fail it doesn't matter
how many times people tell you that you
can't do it it doesn't matter if you
don't have a dime in the fake you will
fill your way to success rule number
four don't lose time is there anything
that you wish you didn't do yes I wish I
had not waited 14 years somebody said if
you want to lose something lose money
you can get that back eight out of ten
millionaires have been financially
bankrupt Walt Disney filed bankruptcy
seven times and had two nervous
breakdowns but don't lose time there
were 14 years I sat on the sidelines 14
years I said I don't have an investor in
me like Tony Robbins
14 years that said I don't have an MBA
or a PhD and and I can't compete with
these guys I have the complexion of
rejection 14 years I silenced mice Wow
and so I regret that because there are
some people that maybe if they'd heard
my voice they would not have turned to
drugs if they'd heard my voice their
lives would have taken a different
direction and I can't hit those 14 years
back that haunts me and me I think that
drives me when I speak with such energy
I'm trying to make up for that time mmm
but I can't rule number five fight for
what you want and one of the things I
emphasize that changing is not easy but
changing your life changing habits
reinventing yourself yeah picking
yourself up after life has knocked you
flat on your back I've got to say when
life knocks you down try and land on
your back because if you can look up you
could get up well that sounds cute
but that's not easy when I was diagnosed
with prostate cancer seventeen years ago
that first time that happened I said hey
I can handle this then when it came back
a year later I mean last year 17 years
later and this time it metastasized to
seven areas of my body and ate 40% of my
tea one vertebrae now the stakes are
higher is this life saying okay mr.
motivator you beat cancer the first time
what you'll do now you know I started
laughing when the doctor Toni said why
are you laughing are you in denial I
said no I said I feel like Mother Teresa
he said what do you mean she said Lord I
know you know how much I can bear I just
wish you don't have so much confidence
in me so the stakes are higher so I've
got to dig in and got to fight more
because at the end of the day life is a
fight for territory and once you stop
fighting for what you want what you
don't want will automatically take over
and so it's a fight it's a challenge in
life every day and what we have to do is
embrace it what we
have to do is see it as a project to be
worked on them
I've read something once that I live by
said in life you will always be faced
with a series of god-ordained
opportunities brilliantly disguised as
problems and challenges and so I see
even cancer as a gift as a god-ordained
opportunity I'd rule number six the last
24 a very special bonus clip is don't
stop running towards your dreams it's
hard changing your life it was hard when
just over three years ago in the
Penobscot building in Detroit Michigan
where I was operating my business and I
fell on some hard times and I was
sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and he said would
you mind reading it here and I open the
envelope and the envelope was from
management that says this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I said excuse
me sir I said I just worked long hours
in creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him it
was hard ladies and gentlemen coming to
speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing
and I can do it there were times that I
doubted myself and say God why why is
this happening to me I'm just trying to
take care of my children and my mother
I'm not trying to steal a Rob from
anybody how did this have to happen to
me it was very hard and here's what I
want to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships don't give up on your
dream no one could have convinced me by
holding on by continuing to push forward
by continuing to run toward my dream
that one day I would have my own talk
show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
order floor never knowing my mother or
father it's a long shot being here with
you today in this dome in Atlanta it's a
long shot
no college training labeled educable
mentally [ __ ] but I kept running
toward my dream
goes down
Goldstar
[Applause]
don't stop running toward your dream now
I've got a special bonus clip from less
on how to embrace the challenges that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where are you losing
time in your calendar every week number
two where do you need to fight harder
for what you want and number three what
do you need to believe more that it's
possible here's what I discovered that
happens to you in life that you will go
through things and while you're going
through them you can't understand why
it's happening to you but after you go
through it you get back and you look at
it and you say oh now I understand why I
needed that lesson have you ever
happened to you is that ever happened to
you that that I did I couldn't
understand it there but after I got
through it then I saw that that was
preparing me for bigger and better
things
but as you go through the challenges of
life and you look at it and embrace
whatever comes to you don't run from it
step toward it don't try and duck it
like most people do see most people want
it easy see if you come easy what easy
go see but when you go at what you're
going to deal with and you deal with the
difficult difficulties of it when you
handle those hard things close at hand
making those hard decisions right now
that you don't want to make learning
those things that you don't like to do
but you know that in order for you to
get where you want to go this is one of
the hoops that you have to flip through
and I'm saying to you whatever you got
to do do it because if you don't life is
gonna whip you until you surrender and
say okay all right all right all right
all right I cooperate okay I'll learn
okay say you had to wear me out a long
time so if it's hard then do it hard
if you want three hours of Les Brown
motivation check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
thank you some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats